à peine arrivé et déjà les premiers
achats jamel est un habitué de cette
enseigne
il est venu dès 8 heures pour profiter
des réductions j'ai pris quelques
articles j'ai pas de budget spécialement
donc je viens ici je choisis je regarde
ce qui me plaît puis voilà pour ce
magasin les deux premières semaines de
soldes représentent 30% du chiffre
d'affaires de la saison
un rendez vous immanquable pour lequel
des responsables se prépare on a une
préparation assez dense déjà depuis la
semaine dernière on a aussi augmenté
énormément les équipes on a quasiment
doublé le staff sur la première semaine
parce que c'est là que tout se joue sur
un mercredi normal on est 4 et là on
évite ce week-end on sera onze ses
seules deux sont les dernières durer six
semaines dès l'an prochain elles seront
à quatre semaines a one nation paris
toutes les boutiques sont prêtes
le centre commercial outlet a ouvert ses
portes deux heures plus tôt pour
accueillir les visiteurs suis venu hier
soir et puis j'ai essayé ce que je
voulais prendre et voilà je suis tant
qu'il ya pas trop de monde pour essayer
de faire les achats rapidement si je
tombe sur quelque chose qui me plaît
mais sinon j'attends toujours les
milieux des sols d'un général les cinq
premiers jours de soldes c'est 30 % de
trafic et cheap de la période des soldes
d'été
je sais que le budget un petit peu moins
fort en été puisque les pièces sont un
petit peu plus fine il n'ya pas les
manteaux etc
mais on est sur des tickets 250 350
euros un panier au dessus de la moyenne
nationale en 2017 les consommateurs
avaient dépensé 200 euros ils ont
jusqu'au 7 août pour finaliser leur
achat pour l'été one nation paris
propose également de nombreuses
activités